[Music]
anything in there catch your eye nothing
that I can afford ain't that the truth
hi I'm Devin and I'm obsessed with the
old Hollywood romance mmm no I'm Jared
and I'm obsessed with cooking and
because we're obsessed with each other
he's gonna cook a dish left behind by an
old Hollywood starlet while I dish on
her love life today we're talking Audrey
Hepburn in her beloved pasta al Pomodoro
recipe here to be a doll and get our
ingredients for us make it as she does
[Music]
right off the bat Pomodoro is actually
just tomato and Italian so we're gonna
start with two large cans of peeled
tomatoes go ahead and grab a large bunch
of basil we're gonna end up using two
tablespoons of olive oil that's a cute
little bottle you got I love that we'll
also need a pound of spaghetti pasta go
ahead and grab the stinkiest parmesan
that we have available or I think we
only staged that one piece so just grab
that two cloves of garlic minced looks
like you bought pre-minced garlic you
know how I feel about prudence to
pre-shredded things but that's fine it's
too late to change now so just to use
that finally we're gonna need two stalks
of celery one small onion and two
carrots which together actually make up
a mirepoix which you'll see in most
recipes for soups stocks and like today
pasta sauces and that's about that
jarred you just taught me something
great so we need the medium we need to
call it something do we yeah like I have
T bits which is just a tidbit of
information but it's gossip it's T it's
a T bit yes we're all familiar with T
bits by now like for an example did you
know that Audrey Hepburn son Shawn
Ferrara Fair Ferrera went on record and
said that she was addicted to carbs and
that she had to have this pasta recipe
that we're about to make at least once a
week it's nice to know that America's
Sweetheart could be addicted to carbs
Wow
stars they're truly just like us see TV
I think I'm cool just calling mind facts
so what do we do first
it's time what does the recipe say right
do you have all of the things we have to
chop up our mirepoix yes we have to put
it in a pot with olive oil and then do
some basil leaves remove the basil
leaves from the stem right and then
and put the tomatoes on top of it and
you read the card okay that's like seven
steps and one let's start by prepping
our veggies okay so we need two socks of
celery diced the recipe calls for two
carrots but I feel like Audrey Hepburn
wasn't cooking with carrots that were
like this giant cuz these are some
genetically modified monsters when I
first looked at this recipe I was
alarmed because it's canned tomatoes and
I kind of thought that we'd want to have
like fresh produce the thing is it's
like hard to get a tomato exactly ripe
enough with canned tomatoes you can be
more sure that they're gonna be like a
consistent ripeness I chopped it I did
it that's too big that needs to be
smaller really yeah cuz the problem came
in too last time your knife skills good
so since we're chopping the vegetables
and having a grand ol time I think it's
time to put a little Audrey Hepburn
backstory up in this [ __ ] Kevin it's
time to get some Audrey Hepburn context
up in this business let me get my little
recipe card out Audrey happened was born
in Brussels Belgium on May 4th 1929
she's a toy her dad was a banker and her
mom was a duchess so fancy in 1935 her
parents divorced she and her mom we're
living in England for a while having a
grand old time but then World War two
started and her mom because she's Dutch
decided that it would be safer to go
back to the Netherlands however she was
wrong
Nazis put a lot of food rations on the
Dutch people in the Netherlands and so
Audrey and her mother dealt with a lot
of malnutrition growing up so they
didn't have a lot of food in fact they
ate with bread and made out of tulip
flower I'm gonna go ahead and start
chopping this onion I was hoping that
you would take that job because I didn't
want to freaking do it oh god you're so
dramatic
I'm not too mad you are so dramatic you
know it helps onion eyes right no red
wine oh is that a fact
yep that's so researcher proof act yep
so have another tea bit for you yay
Audrey there was like some scandal and
she was growing up and her mother
actually renamed her during World War
two because she was kind of afraid at
her name
Audrey sounded too English and she
foreign in the Netherlands so for a
while she went by other oh did you know
that I don't one now you know the point
of the show is that I don't know any of
the things that you're telling me I
still candlelight on the fact that I
know something that you don't know so
now it's actually time to start cooking
we're gonna heat up some of this oil
first it says two tablespoons in the
recipe as soon as this oil is heated up
we're gonna cook down our aromatic
vegetables and then the sauce will
really start coming oh listen to that
sizzle it's a good sizzle I'm not too
upset about that so we just gonna cook
this down for a little bit we don't want
too much browning on this kind of just
want to get everything a little softened
so we don't have any crunchy carrots in
our final sauce is really what we're
worrying about now you bartender I just
know that if you hit mint leaves it
releases the mint some hitting basil is
well you actually want to be pretty
gentle with our herbs cuz they bruise
really easily and we are gonna put some
of those on the top of our dish so we
don't spank them okay we could have
cooked these vegetables a little bit
longer before you added those but that's
fine is there like a spot process to
when you want to add fresh basil is yeah
essentially we're cooking these at like
a medium-high heat to soften them faster
and if you put like a delicate little
herb in there it could potentially burn
that's why I should just let you do the
cooking it is why you should literally
just let me do what you brought me here
to do Jared's actually super mad at me
because instead of buying garlic regular
granular garlic I bought this minced
chopped garlic she's a total waste it's
like 70 times more expensive than just
buying a head of garlic so so good okay
it's a wafting a wafting scent is much
better however much garlic you want I
think it's gonna be fine
I'd like to imagine that Audrey would
like come home from her world travels
and just like quickly throw this
together and I've all the recipe and the
ingredients as well you know what I mean
yeah
baking is a really precise science
cooking is just a free-for-all when do
you know it's time to add the tomato
sauce to that the onions have turned
slightly translucent we definitely want
to burn any
so I think we're actually pretty ready
pretty ready how many does it call for
two cans you can two large cans what
else can I tell you about Audrey at this
point that's okay there you have like a
solid moment of silence and just kind of
enjoy our company I love cooking
primarily because I don't have to talk
while it's happening most of the time
it's just me and my stove and my cats
hello I am Audrey Hepburn we interrupt
this cooking show for an Audrey Hepburn
life update that's right before we can
continue any longer with any of this
juicy gossip we have to cover her young
and early adulthood after World War two
she moved from the Netherlands to London
England to start her career in modeling
in ballet she actually got discovered by
a photographer named Angus McVean it's a
very British name dumb it's not dumb
Angus Macqueen took the picture of her
then pretty much launched her career it
helped her get notice so she could move
to the US in the early 1950s it only
took her a couple years to get a
starring role in an incredible movie
named that Phil Roman Holiday yeah do
you know handle zeroing on it
show me the men I want men okay we're
getting to her love life 1952
Audrey's engaged to a man named James
Hanson what a little she split her time
between being in England with him and
then also doing her work she realized it
was really hard to keep a long-distance
relationship going
homegirl bought a wedding dress and then
called it off she couldn't do it yeah
that's all right after her breakout film
she was enjoying some success she met a
new man his name was Mel Ferrara Ferrer
Ferran been over this before her The
Verge era he kind of looks like the
first guy I had one baby he was the one
who put her on blast for how much she
loved hearts which were still glass
again Thank You Shawn thanks Joe so
here's the thing about Hepburn and
Ferrer she would go off and have some
romance on the side he would do the same
all these infidelity is damaged their
relationship and after 14 years together
if they got a divorce if we rewind the
timeline to 1954 1954 is when she met
this hottie McCotter s'en William Holden
and they met on a set of Sabrina when
she first met this
she thought he was the most handsome man
she's ever met who wants to hear why she
ended her relationship with the hottest
man she's ever met you two okay
it's because he had a vasectomy yeah
pasta without sauce you know what I mean
so 1969 he is a psychologist he is a
neurologist and he looks weird he
definitely looks like a later in life
romance they look married 1969 and she
had her next child in 1970 at the age of
40 with two babies she decided to take a
break from Hollywood she really settled
into domestic life in Italy she would be
seen attending her favorite cafes and
walking the city streets which i think
is just beautiful 12 years later she
ended up getting a divorce it was kind
of a tumultuous time because on that I
had those two you was like cheating on
her all the time it was all over the
papers
there's always pasta which we should get
back to that sauce oh that was a lot of
testosterone let's refocus back on the
food bring it back to carbs better get
it back in the car great so I got a
pound of pasta here Wow
what are you doing I didn't need you to
touch it I just was showing it to you
hope the package directions say that
that's gonna take 10 minutes for al
dente
do you put oil in your water when you
make pasta at home so it doesn't stick
together no no if you just stir it every
once in a while the pasta should not
stick together as it's cooking gotcha
anyway and this time we were sitting
around you mentioned one true love as
you tend to do that was too many dudes
to keep track of who was it I don't know
if Audrey really had I mean I'm sure
personally she had one true love yeah I
would argue that Italian culture and the
city of Rome was like her my biggest
obsession and her one true love okay go
with me here to cop-out it's not a
combat that is a cop-out I think there's
a place in the world where you can feel
like your best self become just like a
soul mate can make you feel like your
best self
I wouldn't know just kidding I would me
know what Audrey Hepburn withdrew from
the spotlight and she stayed in
Rome and when she did she kind of leaned
into Italian culture even more her
favorite recipe which she ate literally
once a week was such a staple of Italian
cuisine I unlike even look at her career
her first picture that launched her
career had those like Roman columns
behind her apparently she was a staple
on the city when she lived there she
didn't just like stay in her house like
she walked around the city she would
talk to tourists neglected to mention
that yeah paints this picture way better
than Audrey Hepburn's one true love
Italy bro
go for it Rome good for you another
thing that this recipe calls for is
Audrey rinsed her pasta I hate that oh
that is like a huge no-no oh no in terms
of like restaurant cooking and
everything I've learned about cooking
like you do not rinse your pasta by your
rinse off all the starch and so it kind
of makes the noodles are really slick
and then no pasta sauce is gonna stick
to that and why would she bring sit if
you're like plating it on the plate and
then putting the pasta sauce on top like
in this recipe it'll make it easier to
twirl
but this pasta sauce is gonna go all
over the place if you want to weaken
shipping on the basil what was that word
what I did I stack the leaves our pastas
done okay so did not plan on that
happening in that order but we got our
pasta we rinse it off back to the ship
and odd I stack the leaves and I'm gonna
roll them up mm-hmm and then you cut
them how fancy much fancy and then you
get these little ribbons which I want to
say is what shipping on means but don't
quote me on that that's not a jarred
effect okay okay should we plate this
stuff up yeah it's plate it just as
Audrey likes it even though I think
she's really wrong so Jared you know how
Audrey Hepburn ate this pasta once a
week I do since you told me that like 30
minutes ago not only she eat this pasta
once a week but she ate two servings
what are you trying to do I just want to
put this on the plate thanks sir do you
like
spin your plate like this you get this
really nice little nest of pasta I guess
it looks very soon it looks nothing it
doesn't look exactly the same I got
better volume sorry what were you saying
so not only did Audrey eat this pasta
once a week
was she a two servings whoa yep that's
what we're gonna do when I say it was
her favorite thanks it was her favorite
there you go see look nest mess mess
here I'll do you first Oh what did you
you will notice that this pasta sauce
will just run all over the place you
were just so mad that we aren't we've
rinsed these noodles that's just not
what you do that's not how life works
you want some cheese or did you not take
your lactate though not to out you I'll
be in front of the entire world that I'm
black doesn't Oh hmm you're just going
for it
mm-hmm okay what I wrote to wait for you
um yeah I made I made this you Brian oh
thank you
Wow about it you deserve it it's good
mmm it has that tomato acid taste but
not too much and it also has like a
little bit of a sweetness to it the
carrots and the celery helped really
bounce that out also onions when you
cook them down get a little sweet -
should we do the lady in the [ __ ] thing
with the noodles
you guys should feed each other should
we yeah - Audrey - do you make eye
contact while we do this bone and the
teeth now that's true love mystery
solved until next time this is mystery
bites
tell us who you whose recipe you want us
to recreate for our next episode also go
home try Audrey's pasta it is good share
it on all social media
because Audrey certainly couldn't and we
got to make up for lost time
I can't eat all the sugars a lot pops
this was a bad idea
oh my god I mean my wine ohh-oh-oh yes
[Music]